today on the matt walsh show the trump
administration is over democrats have
officially assumed total control of the
government
where do we go from here we'll talk
about that today also five headlines
including trump's
confusing pardon of a corrupt democrat
politician
plus the media gets back to licking the
boots of those in powers that's the
position they're comfortable being in
and the mayor of dc defends the
political vetting of troops and
in our daily cancellation we will cancel
multiculturalism all of that and much
more today on the matt wall show
before we get going here today um and
we're going to talk about this we have
more to say about this
as we get into the opening monologue but
you know one question we're all asking
especially today going forward
is what are some things we can do in the
culture to make a difference and i'll
tell you one thing we can do
is to find the companies that support
our values and support them
and that really does make a difference
and that's why i
am a big supporter and i would ask you
to also uh consider charity mobile the
pro-life phone company five percent of
your monthly plan price goes to the
pro-life pro family charity of your
choice when you sign up for charity
mobile
new activations and eligible accounts
get a free cell phone with free
activation and free shipping
so you get a great you get great perks
on top of you know your
your helping in the the fight to build a
culture of life in america
also there's no contracts no termination
fees there's no risk with a 30-day
guarantee
so you might as well try it out if for
some reason you don't like it you're not
locked in but i think you really will
like you also like the fact that you've
got live customer service based in the
usa
and you can always block cellular data
picture messages text messages on any or
all
lines on your account uh and a lot of
other other things too free
you get a free app to monitor your usage
to pay your bills
much more but again what this is really
about you turn
everyday living into effortless giving
for the charity of your choice
uh when you get charity mobile i'm i'm a
charity mobile user
i can't say enough good things about it
you can call them now at 1-877-474-3662
or chat with them online at
charitymobile.com
here we are now at the end of
all things well the end of the trump
administration so not all things but
that thing
at least joe biden a man with the mental
acuity and
awareness of an oyster is now in the
white house where he will be
taken by the hand guided into a closet
somewhere given some coloring books to
keep him busy
while camilla harris runs the government
and it will be let's face it a radically
far-left government the most far-left
government in american history by a mile
we can pretty much guarantee that
to make matters worse there will be no
constraints there will be
no no no restraining it they will be
unfettered they will be free like birds
to fly off and fulfill their
marxist dreams republicans you know
aren't good for much as we've learned
especially when it comes to actually
enacting and acting upon their own
agenda but they can at least play
defense they're decent at that
they can block the democrat agenda even
if they can't or wish
won't push forward their own when they
have the power only now
they will be unable or certainly at
least less able to block anything given
that the democrats won georgia and thus
the senate
the republicans could have won georgia
if not for the fact that the georgia
race became a
circus sideshow of grifters and carnival
barkers
raising money for their own benefit
while telling republicans to stay home
and forfeit congress
to the left also not helping matters the
republican candidates in those races
could not themselves
have been any less exciting or less
inspiring if they tried
and they did try it seemed the upshot is
that again
democrats have full control and they
will exploit that control to the fullest
possible extent
they will show us what it looks like
when power is wielded
make no mistake they will do everything
that they
have the legal right to do and a whole
bunch of things that they do not have
the legal right to do
democrats impose their will when given
the opportunity love him or hate him and
i'm very much
a member of the second club the fact is
that
when when when put into a position of
power the democrats
do what their voters put them there to
do
republicans on the other hand twiddle
their thumbs and bide their time
waiting to be out of power again so they
can finally pretend to care about the
agenda
that they didn't enact when they had the
chance to do it
democrats don't play that game as we
have seen and we will
see even more in the years ahead making
matters worse
the democrats have a taste for vengeance
now taste for blood
they feel that those who inflicted the
last four years upon them those
responsible for making it happen
so you know 75 million people or so
should pay for what they've done
and they are determined to prevent such
indignities
from ever happening again whatever
progress may have been made in the last
four years whatever good may have been
done
it's all mostly stuff that can be easily
reversed and undone
mostly by executive order trump actually
reversed some of it himself on the way
out the door for example rescinding his
own executive order banning
administration officials
from taking lobbyist jobs within within
five years of leaving government
so trump trump saved biden the paperwork
on that one i guess
the rest biden or his handlers can do on
their own without much trouble
meanwhile the conservative movement is
fractured into a million pieces
trump leaves office impeached and
deplatformed facing the possibility of a
senate conviction
many others uh many other much less
famous conservatives have also been
de-platformed and censored
with the powers that be currently
dreaming up ways to silence the rest of
us
we are under suspicion we are under
attack
the left won by whatever means necessary
and now we are on the outside
we are scattered we are disorganized we
are weakened
that's the reality of the situation it's
best now that we look it straight in the
eyes as uncomfortable as it may be i'm
not here to tell you fairy tales or
delude you into a false sense of
security
the right has been deluding itself for
far too long telling itself stories
about
secret plans and 4d chess and insisting
that everything will magically work out
in the end
up until last night i saw people still
insisting that trump would remain in
office today
and the plan would unfold and everything
would be okay
they held on to the delusion until the
bitter end
some of them probably still holding on
to it even now i wouldn't be surprised
if the new theory is that trump is
really president still
and is secretly running the government
from his batcave somewhere
i'm not joking this is this is what some
people will believe
those of us with the boldness to face
reality though will face it
and reality is as i have described it
here
so the question is what now where do we
go from here what does the road ahead
look like
is all hope lost are we doomed should we
give up
well i can answer those last three
questions with a no no and no
hope is not lost we're not doomed and we
should not give up as for what exactly
happens or what precisely the future
holds that i don't know for certain
nobody does but i do know
that even if we're bruised and beaten at
present we are not in a hopeless state
despair is not the answer and though i
may be
known as a guy who can be quite bleak at
times i'm not exactly a ray of sunshine
i must admit
i have never been in despair and i am
not now and you shouldn't be either
despair is what happens when you have
not only no hope but no meaning in your
life despair is when you wake up and
look around
and you can't see that your life has any
purpose
it's when everything is empty or appears
to be from your perspective
you know i i would hope that nobody
would ever be tempted to feel this way
because of political events
but from the sound and look of it it
seems that some people really are
teetering close to that
it's not that these are trump-obsessed
cultists who can't bear to live without
the man
it's that is that they they look around
and they see that our government
and our institutions are overrun and run
by people who hate them
and they think it's all lost and there's
nothing ahead but more defeat
and there's no point that's where the
despair comes in
but it shouldn't in fact there is a
silver lining to our present condition
the silver lining is that now
conservatives can stop looking to one
man in washington to save them
and save their families and instead
focus on making an
impact where it really matters and where
it can really be felt
you know the fight going forward is
where it's always been
though we've neglected and ignored it
focusing instead on national politics as
though national politics is the be-all
and end-all
the fight is in our communities it's in
the culture on the local level
the true battle for everything is
happening right around us
right now directly around us
and we can make a profound impact there
if we're willing to put in the effort
let me just give you one tangible
example
the school system millions of children
do you hear me railing about this all
the time millions of children are sent
into these buildings or into zoom
meetings now i guess
where they are conditioned and
indoctrinated into the doctrines of the
far left
yet we could have only republican
presidents for the next 50 years
it would make almost no difference
culturally as long as we keep feeding
our kids into this system
this is something we can change we can
change it
right now we could but it takes work
it's not always fun
we can pull our kids out we can form
homeschool co-ops
supporting each other in our communities
taking charge of our children's
education
we can do this we can do that
lots of us are already doing it if
enough of us do it
we can radically change the culture in
immeasurable ways
overnight no matter what anyone in
washington says or does 50 million
children are currently enrolled in
public schools 50 million
cut that number in half let's say we
could have democrat presidents for the
next 50 years
and that would that would also almost
not matter at all because we will have
so significantly taken back control
of our own families and thus the culture
the condition of the family is what
determines the condition
of the culture
this as i said is just one example there
are plenty of others including in the
realm of politics local politics go to
your town hall meetings figure out who
your local
council members are do you even know
these people have more control over you
than you think
speak out when things are happening in
your neighborhood and community that you
don't like
protests the drag queen story hours this
stuff matters
don't listen to people who tell you it
doesn't
in fact at this point any conservative
who tells you that the culture wars
don't matter
please if if they're going to be any
change we make disregard them
dispense of them throw them out we don't
need them
how can you expect your voice to have
any impact on anything
if there are drag queens performing for
children at your local library
two blocks away and you say nothing
and do nothing about it
well we can't do anything about it
really we can't
if all the people in the community that
didn't like it showed up at that library
you don't think that'd be enough to put
an end to it it would
it happens because we don't show up and
we don't
do anything we could
but we don't it's not all a matter of
protesting things either you know on the
other end of it we can support
the people who are making a positive
difference donate to your local
pregnancy center
give to your church get involved in your
church these are all things we can do
there are plenty of other things too it
may not be dramatic or flashy
but the real work of fighting to reclaim
the culture and your country is
rarely dramatic or flashy
the real work is being done by serious
sober-minded people
usually without fanfare and without
notice
that's where our focus should be it's
where our hope lies
it's why i haven't given up quite the
contrary i'm ready to fight
fight in a meaningful way and i hope you
are too
so let's get to it and now time for our
five headlines
all right um i know we just uh had a
serious talk there about all the things
in the culture to fight for
can i just mention one other thing not
quite as serious but it's on my mind
because
right before i went on the air here i
was i was in the break room
and uh somebody brought donuts to the
office
and there's a you know box of donuts
there and there's this moment of course
when you walk into the break room and
there's a box of donuts
and a moment of joy when you see that
box
and you think my the whole day is made a
free done i wasn't expecting this
and but then what what always happens
you open the box
and this is what just happened to me
nothing but powdered doughnuts and jelly
donuts in there
that's all that's left there's like one
half of a powdered and then a few jelly
donuts left
okay here's my point
why do we bother putting these trash
filler donuts in the box they are always
the last ones left everybody knows this
at at the end of the day there's always
a couple of donuts left and they're
always the jelly and powdered donuts
so when you're going to dunkin donuts to
get the donut why
tell it's not like they're cheaper why
tell them to put those filler donuts in
there in the first place
stick with the classics the ones
everyone likes glazed
chocolate there's never a glaze left
where's the last time you pick up a box
and there's a glaze left
never those get eaten
this is very important this is another
thing we could do to reclaim the culture
let's get it
get control of the way that we uh set up
our
dot boxes of donuts okay number one uh
trump
released his list of pardons earlier
today um lots of people hoping he'd
pardon assange and snowden
that didn't happen instead he he
pardoned some rappers uh some drug
dealers
he pardoned pardon lil wayne
he pardoned this guy kodak black as a
rapper
by the way a rapper who who i believe
made a music video
where he's portrayed choking a a a
a trump supporter he's an anti-trump
rapper's
trump commute commuted his sentence um
also
one of the guys who uh one of the guys
behind death row records back in the 90s
also a drug kingpin he was arrested for
a bunch of charges including
kidnapping and attempted murder and he
got a pardon
because his friend snoop dogg asked
trump
now snoop dogg also has a video and in
his video i think he's actually killing
trump himself
not actually trump but uh an actor but
he asked for a pardon he got one
assange snowden didn't also this is kind
of confusing the
the ex um ex detroit mayor kwame
kilpatrick
got a pardon democrat mayor
cartoonishly corrupt this guy is
he's like the he's like the mascot for
corrupt politicians
he pretty much did everything that a
corrupt politician could possibly do
he was corrupt in every possible way
um very efficient in that way in his in
his corruption
let me read a little bit from the
detroit free press on this it says u.s
attorney matthew schneider
who has long argued that kilpatrick
deserves his 28-year prison sentence and
should not be released early from his
crimes
blasted the commutation decision he said
my position on the disgraced former
mayor of detroit has not changed kwame
kilpatrick has earned every day he
served in federal prison for the
horrible crimes he committed against the
people of detroit
he is a notorious and unrepentant
criminal schneider added kilpatrick has
served only one quarter of the sentence
that was very appropriately imposed
thankfully thankfully under michigan law
he cannot hold state or local public
office for 20 years after his conviction
um but detroit mayor mike dugan democrat
had a different take he said call me
kilpatrick is a person of great talent
who still has much to contribute
i know how close he is to his three sons
and i could not be happier for them
being together again this is the
decision that president trump got right
so it's not even that he's innocent or
he didn't commit no he committed the
crimes but he's talented and
um you know he has he has kids so just
just let him out of prison
um kilpatrick who resigned from office
in 2008 following a text message scandal
disclosed by the free press has been
serving a 20-year
28-year federal prison sentence
following his 2013 conviction
on multiple corruption crimes including
racketeering bribery extortion and fraud
all of his appeals failed over the years
though both kilpatrick and a group of
supporters
uh including millionaire businessman
peter caramos
had appealed to trump last year seeking
clemency
and now he gets it he does have a lot of
debt though
um a lot of debt uh stemming from
uh the the fraud and corruption that he
committed while in office
bilking the taxpayers i mean this this
is just
this again is a corrupt politician who
actually got what he deserves he got
30 you got three decades in prison thank
god right
how many of these people get away with
it get to go on become lobbyists or
whatever they you know they stay in
office
he actually went to prison for once
and then trump comes along and says
never mind you get out of prison
you're good it is
just outrageous uh law and order
right law and order folks this is what
law and order is all about
meanwhile trump also has in that he
hasn't said this himself but he
is reported to have entertained the idea
of starting his own political party
third party
that he would call the patriot party i
like the name you know i'll say that
much about it but i will say though
you know whatever your position is on
this just just so you know
um if somebody comes along from the
right
and makes a serious attempt at a third
party here is what will happen we could
put aside any fantasies about what
what we hope happens or just let's talk
about again we're dealing with reality
here's what will absolutely happen if we
get a third party from the right
and it actually gets some attention like
it actually actually tracks
some people um it makes a serious run
what will happen is that we will have
democrat
super majorities in congress and a
democrat president for the next 20 years
or really forever they'll just be in
office forever
because the the opposition can
can can we barely have enough numbers as
it is now
you split it in two or in the third you
start you start fracturing
there's no chance we just don't have the
numbers we can't do it
so that is a i i i just a horrible idea
um and that is not something that we
should at all entertain
but again in fairness this is just a
report from the media i don't think
trump said it himself so
hopefully it's all it is just something
for the media okay the mayor of dc mayor
bowser
speaking of uh bad mayors had some
things to say in a press conference
yesterday
um let's let's take a listen to that
yesterday i was also
heartened to see washingtonians posting
photos of their neighborhoods on social
media
and tagging them with we are dc
it is a much needed reminder to the
world that our city has so much
to offer outside of the federal enclave
and actually all of these neighborhoods
are what will become the 51st state of
washington dc
so keep sharing those photos
make sure that you're signed up for
inauguration alerts
remember that if you see something
unusual
say something when you have um guards
coming guards men and women
coming from all over the country at this
time
i do think uh that it is is prudent
uh to make sure that that they are being
vetted
uh and that anybody who cannot pledge
allegiance to
to their mission and may be
pulled by other views needs not only to
be removed from this duty they need to
be removed from the guard
okay so we have a couple of couple of
things there first of all she's talking
about statehood for dc
um you want to talk about another thing
that will guarantee
democrats in office forever that there's
another one
and that's what and that's why i said
democrat now i don't know if that's
actually going to happen or not
but uh puerto rico they want statehood
puerto rico too
but once again democrats when they have
power
they use it they will use their power
when they have it and they're going to
use it this time
not republicans though that that's the
dirty little secret about republicans
that
that at this point i hope is not really
a secret i hope everyone's caught on to
it by now
they don't actually like being empowered
now they they might like some aspects of
of having political power
they look like some of the perks that
comes with it the prestige the money
the the the opportunities uh for money
both legally and not
but the responsibility that comes with
power of actually having to do all the
things that you said you were going to
do
that's the part they don't like and so
they much prefer to be in power but to
not actually have the ability to do much
with it
that for them is the sweet spot
democrats say whatever
say whatever you want about them they
actually they don't want
just the prestige of being in power they
want they want the control too
they want that because they they want to
do something with it
and that's what we're going to see here
and then also she's talking about
political
uh vetting vetting of the troops
political vetting
and this is just blatantly illegal
but once again this is what they
this is what they can do and will do
number three i have to say this is
almost comforting just in its normalcy
for the media to be back to doing what
it does best
which is licking the boots of those in
power they haven't been able to do this
really at all in the last four years and
you could tell they've been starving
they've been starving for some boots
and uh now now or or some chuck taylor's
as you know that's why they're so
obsessed with um
with camila harris's shoe choices so now
they can get back they can assume the
position and they can get back to doing
what they love to do
and uh here's it and here you you just
see the glee on their face like finally
once again
we can worship those in power here's
somebody on
on cnn talking about fantasizing really
about joe biden embracing the whole
country joe biden
reaching out his arms and embracing the
country
um now personally i don't want joe biden
to embrace
me but let's listen to this and the
contrast on display tonight was so stark
i mean those lights that are that are
just
shooting out from the lincoln memorial
along the reflecting pool
i look it's like almost uh extensions of
joe biden's arms
embracing america embracing america
oh yeah he joe biden will embrace
america all right he'll embrace us all
it's joe biden reaching out and if you
will sniffing the hair of america
he is he is sniffing our collective hair
only i'm not very comforted by that
and this paternalistic this is this is
the thing that's going to really
nauseate me um you know the hero worship
the
the idolatry of politicians i'm not a
fan of that but
especially when it takes on this sort of
paternalistic
flavor as if this is our our
our great father that we are looking to
for comfort in this time
but also it could take on a religious
flavor and that's what we hear now on
msnbc listen
thinking about all of those folks who
just for the moment
the nation shared their grief
oh what a first step what a beautiful
step so i'm i'm gonna you know i'm
reminded of the psalmist
you know he heals the brokenhearted and
binds up their wounds
um maybe the death will speak to us now
maybe they can rest now
it sounds to me like he's
i don't misinterpret him but it sounds
like
he is comparing
joe biden to god as healing the
brokenhearted
repairing our wounds yeah that's that
yeah i think i think that's i think
i think that's what he was going for of
course during the primaries you know it
goes without saying but the
the media wasn't saying any of this
really about about biden during the
primaries
uh or especially camille harris so this
religious idolatry
this uh you know this this embracing him
is this almost godlike
character that only happens after he
wins obviously
all right number four axios has a story
about that garden of heroes that trump
was trying to get off the ground
who knows what will happen with that now
but um that was
all the statues of american heroes that
that trump wants to erect
love the idea as as i said yesterday uh
i think whenever republican is in office
if that ever happens again
uh they should just put up statues all
over the place and yeah the democrats
can come back around and start tearing
them down
but just we it's just a it's a war of
attrition now just keep putting up the
statues
make them bigger and bigger and bigger
that's why i say
2024 republican primaries whichever
republican gets
up there and promises to build
a 50-foot statue of christopher columbus
and put it right in the middle
of washington d.c i will vote for that
person i don't even care who it is
but um axios is complaining because
their headline is
trump's american heroes are 73 percent
men
delivering on a promise he made at mount
rushmore this summer president trump
yesterday released his 244 candidates
for a national guard of american heroes
by the numbers men outnumber women
nearly four to one
86 of the nominees nearly a third were
born between 1900 and 1950
uh and then we get some of the other
numbers but i guess we're supposed to be
upset
about that that so many of them are men
yo
there is you could see that as sexist if
you want to
the other way of looking at it is wow
there have been a lot of men who are
american heroes that's great maybe we
should be grateful to them
you know maybe men aren't so horrible
after all
maybe toxic masculinity isn't such a bad
thing because when you go back through
history and you look at american history
and
many of the people not everybody but
many of the people who have achieved
great things and have helped to
form and establish this civilization
that we all are living in
we're men
well maybe a little bit of gratitude
just a thought number five report from
oregon live it says a car thief who
discovered a small child in the back
seat of the suv he boosted on saturday
in beaverton
drove back to the child's mother
demanded she take the child
out of the back seat and drove off once
more according to police
officer matt henderson said uh he
actually lectured the mother for leaving
the child in the car and threatened to
call the police on her
the crime occurred at 9 10 a.m in the
parking lot of basics meat market
the mother parked just outside the store
from the the store's front door went
inside to buy a gallon of milk and some
meat
she was never more than 15 feet from the
car but she made a critical error
she left the engine running and the
doors unlocked what she did was not a
crime she was within sight and sound of
her child
but she left the car running so that
extra step take the car keys with you
it's a good reminder to take extra
precaution when we have our little ones
this is the uh
police officer being quoted anyway in
that little bit of time car thief jumped
into the car
didn't realize there were kids in there
and he drives off and then sees the kid
turns around comes back delivers the kid
gives the mother a little lecture about
parenting safety and then drives off
you know this thing um i don't want to
get myself into trouble but
this stuff about leaving kids in the car
oh you never leave a kid in the car ever
even for even for one second i mean i
hear from from mothers who
this is their excuse when i go off on my
my normal rant
about returning car uh your your
shopping cart in the parking lot and
one of the excuses i hear from others
and i assume this is just an excuse
or maybe they really mean it necessarily
is that they don't want to leave their
kid in the car
to return the uh shopping cart
it's like so what you're saying is you
you don't want to leave your kid in the
car
and walk 20 feet away when you could see
the car the whole time
you won't even do that what do you think
is gonna happen
now yes in this in this extreme
circumstance the car was actually stolen
but even then
just to show you how how you know how
rare it is actually that the kids are
kidnapped by strangers
it almost never happens in almost every
single case where it happens it's a
family member so even in this case it
was a bad guy stole the car he still
came back around and said
here's your kid um so really that's not
much of a concern
so i don't i don't i don't quite
understand this idea of like you never
ever i mean obviously you got a young
kid it's 100 degrees outside you don't
leave your kid in
a in a locked car no ac obviously you
don't do that
but it's a mild day out no concern you
lock the door
you just you run 15 feet away
come back i don't see a problem i i when
i was a kid this was really common
i don't get my parents in trouble but i
feel like when i was a kid right when
when
like my generation when we were kids
this i i can remember many a time of
like waiting in the car for my parents
to go do something
was it wasn't hot we weren't you know we
weren't dying from the heat but
it's a pretty common thing back in the
day and it's just another thing that
we've decided now
there are so many things that our
parents used to do and
it was normal for parents to do for
generations
and now we've decided that if you do
that thing you are an abuser and
and you should go to prison
so many kind of like shortcuts and just
little things like that that our parents
were allowed to do
we can't do that anymore not for any
like statistical or
reason but jess we've decided you can't
do that so
there's a long way of saying i am i'm
going to defend the mother on this
on this one just don't you know yeah
probably don't leave the car
keys in the car and the door unlocked in
the future
you might have this on your mind um
thinking about
catastrophes emergencies disasters i
don't know you might be thinking about
that today
and if you are then you got to make sure
that you prepare
prepare yourself for any emergencies
that uh that
that might come up that's you know part
of just being an adult
uh being a grown-up is to be prepared
and that's where ready wise comes in
ready wise is the leader in emergency
food supplies
and and they also are have have a lot of
different products they've got emergency
meals
they've got freeze-dried fruits and
vegetables for convenient on-the-go
nutrition they also got adventure meals
for hiking and camping
uh if you like to go outdoors you know
as as i do
you want to grab something really quick
before you're heading out maybe going
for a hike or something and you can grab
their adventure meals as well ready-wise
makes being prepared simple and
affordable you can order online and have
nutritious meals shipped directly to
your doorstep ready-wise
products are proudly made in the usa so
you're supporting an american company
who makes their products in the usa
readywise makes being prepared simple
and affordable you can order online have
nutritious meals shipped directly to
your doorstep
when preparing um there are meals all
you need
is four cups of water the water doesn't
even have to be hot so you really don't
need much you simply pour the food into
the water you stir and cover about 15
minutes
the meal is ready some meals can even be
prepared directly in the pouch
eliminating the need for extra
additional supplies
just this is something you want to do i
would i would recommend going to
readywise.com
looking at all their options and
thinking about this today
uh because if you get to a point where
you feel like you needed to have this
well then it's too late it's too late to
be prepared after the fact so go now
this week my listeners can get 10 off
readywise.com
uh readywise.com when entering walsh at
checkout or by calling 855-475-3089
ready wise has a 30-day no questions
asked return policy so there's no risk
in taking the initiative to get you
and your family prepared today that's
readywise r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e.com promo
code walsh to get 10
off and uh we've been telling you of
course about
run hide fight which is our new movie
last thursday was when we
when we uh got into the entertainment
space finally our first foray certainly
not gonna be our last
and uh if you want to see what
everybody's talking about and watch this
movie
you can stream it on demand from our
website mobile or streaming apps on
apple tv and roku
if you aren't a member yet then here's
what you got to do use promo code rhf to
get 25
off that's rhf for 25 off as we've been
telling you
like this is a movie that the people
like it's got 95 96 percent
rating at rotten tomatoes 14 from the
critics critics don't like it the people
do
side with the people i say especially
when it comes to movies
we're excited to bring you great stories
that hollywood refuses to tell and we
hope you'll join us and become a member
today over at dailywire.com and remember
you get 25
off when you use promo code rhf so go
watch the movie but first we will get to
our daily cancellation
today for our daily cancellation we're
going to cancel multiculturalism
now what precipitates this cancellation
as a tweet from the now former secretary
of state mike pompeo
pompeo as i'm informed by the new york
times infuriated many american diplomats
and many other americans when he
attacked multiculturalism
saying this he tweeted this woke-ism
multiculturalism all the isms they're
not who america
is they distort our glorious founding
and what this country is all about our
enemies stoke these divisions because
they know they make us weaker
that's what he said mike pompeo now this
of course is completely true
and well said and the sort of
politically incorrect truth that we
certainly will not hear emanating from a
presidential administration at any point
again in the next four years
um he was condemned though as a racist
for this just one example our dear
friend ibram x kendi said
in a multicultural society like the us
what happens when people oppose
multiculturalism
well they the uh this they standardize
the cultures of white folk
call them america implore the rest of us
to assimilate
when we refuse and opt to be ourselves
freely they call us anti-american
authoritarians
that's what kendi said now this is an
interesting critique because he
references the culture of white folk
but i've been reliably informed that
white folk don't have a culture i've
been told that
there's no such thing as white culture
i've been told that this is precisely
the reason why white people aren't
allowed to talk about white pride or
express any positive or affirming
feelings about being white i've been
told that other races or ethnicities are
allowed to
have pride in their race and their
ethnicity because
they are you know really expressing
pride in their culture and their
heritage
but white people don't have a culture or
heritage i have been told
so that if a white person says he has
white pride what he really means is that
he's racist
now though even rex candy who we recall
is an expert in matters of race he'll
tell you himself
he says that white culture is a thing
does that mean that white pride is back
on the table
well no because you see white people
have a culture but the culture is racism
that's all that defines a white person
so if you have pride in your white
culture
you have pride in racism which means
you're racist
you're also racist regardless because
all white people are inherently you know
it's not racist to say that about white
people though because only white people
can be racist
which is a pretty sweet deal for
everybody else you know everyone else
you just say whatever you want
can't be racist but this is all
irrelevant anyway because the critique
of multiculturalism has
nothing to do with race culture if you
believe the dictionary is the customs
arts social institutions and
achievements of a particular nation
people
or social group what this means is that
a multicultural country
not multi-racial multicultural is one
where there is a hodgepodge of customs
institutions arts etc
and if there is such a hodgepodge such a
multiple of cultures
that means there is no shared culture
there is no shared american experience
if america is a multicultural country
then america is a culture-less
country this is the paradox if a country
has multiple cultures
then it has no culture and so the
critique of multiculturalism in america
is not that there are too many cultures
but that there isn't any culture we have
no
shared cultural identity as a nation and
if we do not have any
shared cultural identity then we do not
have a cultural identity
unless our shared identity is our lack
of one
christopher mccandless who wrote a whose
whose story was documented in the book
and then the movie into the wild
worth watching the movie uh by the way
if you haven't seen it
he left his family and friends to go off
into the wilderness
um decades ago eventually he traveled
all the way to alaska where he lived in
the forest for a time before dying after
eating some poisonous berries
shortly before he died he wrote in his
notebook happiness is only real
when shared that's the lesson he learned
in his journey and he learned it the
hard way we're learning a similar lesson
also the hard way we're learning that
culture culture is only real
when shared and that's the problem with
multiculturalism
the left would say that this is not a
problem that cultures can all live
together in the same country in harmony
and
with a common sense of purpose but if
that's possible at all which i doubt
they are the very ones making sure that
it does not happen
because they pit cultures against each
other rank them on a hierarchy of
victimhood
and insist that cultures do not share
anything with each other
now perhaps in theory the multicultural
experiment
could work if all of the cultures shared
and were influenced by each other
forming the fabled melting pot that we
used to hear so much about
i'm skeptical about whether such a thing
could even happen theoretically but we
know that it's not happening in reality
and the very people pushing
multiculturalism
are the ones ensuring that it doesn't
we cannot borrow from a culture or be
influenced by another culture because
because then we're accused of
appropriation as if a culture claims
actual proprietary rights over its
customs and
customs and cuisine and art and if
somebody else from the outside partakes
in it
then somehow the members of that culture
are losing something
they're having something taken from them
you know if you wear a uh
you know the traditional outfit of
another culture
then then in some way somehow that means
that
what you're stealing it from someone in
that culture they are now being deprived
of something because you're wearing the
same thing they do
if multiculturalism could work it
certainly will
not work if the interactions between
cultures
is treated as a zero-sum game
and that is how the left treats it all
but guaranteeing that their own
experiment
will fail fail at least to produce a
prosperous and healthy country
if that was their goal but if the goal
is to produce a shiftless weak and
decadent country
then it has succeeded beautifully and
that is their goal and so we have to say
that in fact they have succeeded
but it's not a very good one not a very
very good goal and that's why
multiculturalism
today is canceled
we talk about what to do to fight for
the culture giving you some ideas
i'll tell you this is another thing i'm
going to do i'm putting the work in okay
for the next four years i am going to be
canceling stuff
that makes a difference somehow i hope
but probably not we'll leave it there
for today thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling our technical
director is austin stevens
production manager pavel voldowski the
show is edited by danny d'amico
our audio is mixed by mike coromina hair
and makeup is done by nika geneva
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matte wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
today on the ben shapiro show president
trump gives his farewell address and the
media go full meg ryan in when harry met
sally
over joe biden of all human beings
that's today on the ben shapiro show
give it a listen